The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So we've
had a mix of lectures
in terms of focusing on
specific topics and the details
of models with notation.
Sometimes that's coupled with
an overview of the literature
to put the paper in context.
Sometimes-- and today
will be an example--
we're just going to
try to do one thing
and do it reasonably
well, although there
is a lot of material today.
There are other things that were
listed on the reading list--
Cynthia Kinnan's job
market paper, for example.
As we go through this, I'll
point out what she was doing
and how that compares to
what we're doing today.
I deliberately decided not
to go through her paper
on the front end of this because
it just chews up more time.
And there's been
that macro lecture,
and maybe the
labor lecture was--
filled a lot of material.
And I'm sort of in the
mood of doing a smaller
thing well today rather than
trying to cover too much.
So there is a
background, though,
and that is constraints.
We've been talking about
constraints all semester.
Consumption
smoothing literature,
including not just
full insurance,
but permanent income,
buffer stock, those.
We did the standard
incomplete markets literature.
There's private
information stuff.
We have mentioned it in
class from time to time,
have not done too
much explicitly,
although the Ben Moll paper
and the others that lecture
were macro models
based on assumptions
about information structures.
Limited commitment we've
actually done quite a lot--
not just how it affects
consumption, but also
in those macro models.
So anyway, there's a consumption
literature out there.
There's a bunch of investment
literature out there
which includes adjustment
cost, sensitivity of investment
to cash flow, structural
modeling, and just
outright reduced-form
empirical papers.
And I've already mentioned
some of this macro literature,
like incomplete markets.
Some of these papers we covered
in class, not all of them.
And finally we
get to this, which
is small but growing
literature trying to test
across different models.
Most of the above
pick one thing to do
and try to do it really well.
Some compare across
maybe two models and some
even more than two.
So I could probably add two
or three more References.
There just isn't
that much out there
that systematically are agnostic
about what the underlying
constraint is and set
out to discover the best
fit against the data, and hence
what the obstacles really are.
So the point is we're not going
to just look at investment,
not just look at consumption.
Largely we will look
at both together.
We're not going to look
at just incomplete markets
or endogenous
information-constrained
markets.
We're going to test for them,
both classes within and across,
and talk about how to do it
and what kind of data we need.
The tools-- we're solving
these dynamic models.
We can allow any number of
financial information regimes.
We're going to use
maximum likelihood
to estimate the parameters,
which allows us to be more
general in a couple of ways.
First of all, we can back out
all the structural parameters,
not just the parameters that are
in a particular Euler equation.
And likewise, we can have more
than one equation, so to speak.
We can look not only at
consumption Euler equations,
but investment rate
of return equations.
So again, I think in
my mind, at least,
these are familiar
themes that we've
been covering in bits
and pieces in each
of the various lectures.
What was Cynthia doing
in her job market paper?
She was looking at various
financial information regimes,
but focusing on the
Euler equations.
And as you go from
full risk sharing
to limited information
about output
to moral hazard,
constrained insurance,
the form of the Euler
equation varied from one
to the other, including what
variable should or should not
show up as lags.
And the basis of
her task was to see
whether lagged inverse
marginal utility was
a sufficient statistic.
I'll say more about
that as we go through.
So there's a long
list of regimes.
I think part of
the point of this
is that the technology
is available to test
almost any regime subject to
computational constraints.
So under incomplete
markets, we get out
of autarky, which is
the worst, savings
only as in buffer stock,
maybe borrowing up to a limit.
We've talked about that
in the natural borrowing
limit and other limits, and
then a single risk-free asset,
which is like permanent
income, unlimited borrowing
and lending.
And then we have the
endogenously determined
incomplete regimes, namely moral
hazard, limited commitment,
hidden output,
unobserved investment,
and the least constrained
regime, the full information
regime.
So there's six or
seven of them here.
And we're going to
go through tools
that allow you to test one
against the other pairwise
for any pair depending on
what data you want to use.
So there is a mechanism
design contract theory
part which we've been putting
off until today, largely.
There is dynamic programming
as in value functions.
We have been seeing
versions of that
through various other lectures.
There's linear programming.
I'm going to say
why momentarily,
although we were
already starting
to do that when we did
Rogerson's paper on labor
supply.
And although it was probably
hard to figure it out,
that's what Victor Zorn
was doing in the TA session
last Thursday.
And maximum likelihood, which
sounds familiar, anyway.
So we compute, we estimate,
and we test, basically.
We can do it on actual data.
I'm going to focus on the
contrast between the urban data
and the rural data.
We can actually use
it on simulated data.
So I vote for this
technique, which is generate
the data from the model itself.
Then you know for sure
what's generating the data
and see whether
you get back what
you put in in terms of
the financial regime
and the underlying parameters.
And the results are reassuring
subject to measurement error.
One comment-- that you have
to be patient to get to the--
get through the next
45 minutes or so--
the criticism of
maximum likelihood
is it's kind of black boxy.
You don't really know, other
than trying to fit histograms--
it's not like you're
focusing on ROA
and how it varies with
wealth or transitions
in the capital stock, or for
that matter, the time series
that the model is generating.
But I'll come back
at the end and show
you the pictures
of the actual data,
and you'll get-- you've
seen it, actually.
But I'll remind you parts
of it, and you'll see why--
what it is that makes
it difficult for some
of these financial regimes to
fit the data and hence what
the obstacles seem
to be out there.
We use the Thai data because
we have both the consumption
and the asset and income data,
and using both is helpful.
But that doesn't mean these
techniques are limited
to rather special databases.
Mostly if you have
surveys of firms,
they would not ask about the
consumption of the owner.
Fortunately, the
reverse is not so--
is less constraining, which
is household-level surveys
done by the World Bank,
Living Standards Measurement
and the FLS, Family Life
Cycle in Mexico and Indonesia,
and so on.
They do typically ask
the household a lot
about their enterprises.
But we've done this in Spain
with just data on investment.
So the techniques work even when
you don't have the consumption
data itself.
And one of the main
findings, reassuringly-- it's
not like we always get
the same thing back.
For one thing, we don't
get full risk sharing much.
Sometimes we do.
It will not surprise
you when we get it
given the other papers
we've discovered in class.
The big interesting
thing is there
is a difference between the
rural data and the urban data.
And the rural data, fairly
limited financial regimes,
like savings only or
limited borrowing,
they fit the best when you use
the investment and income data.
But in the urban
areas, even when
you use the investment
and income data,
you get something less
constraining like moral hazard.
So arguably, the
information problem--
or if you believe
in missing markets,
they're more missing
in the rural areas
than they are in
the urban areas.
All right.
So here's the model, utility
over consumption and effort.
Output is stochastic.
Instead of writing
output as a function
of effort and
capital plus a shock,
this is a more
general histogram.
You've seen it at
least once before,
the probability of any
given output given effort
and capital.
Households are
either on their own
or entering into contracts
with a financial intermediary.
It's partial equilibrium facing
some exogenous outside return.
And you can think about
financial intermediaries
as being competitive
if you want.
You could also think
about it as a stand-in
for the community as a whole.
I'll show you where
this stuff matters.
And you're going to
solve this contracting
problem for many
dates, even potentially
over an infinite horizon.
OK.
And finally, how many
people do we have?
You could actually think
about this as a risk-neutral
household running a business--
sorry-- risk-averse
household running a business
facing a risk-neutral
intermediary as if they're
only two people.
But a lot of what
we do is easier
to interpret when there is
a continuum-- many, many,
a continuum of
household enterprises.
Because then we can talk about
the fractions of households
who took effort,
had certain capital,
and experienced
a certain output.
That actually
eliminates uncertainty
from the point of view
of the intermediary
because all these
things average out.
Yes, Matt.
AUDIENCE: Can they re-contract
each period [? for the ?]
[? consumer? ?]
PROFESSOR: Here we're
largely ruling it out.
There is some limited
commitment in the sense
that they can walk away
and go into autarky.
That's about as close
as we get in this paper.
I kind of know something
about how to extend it,
but it's not going to
be in the lecture today.
AUDIENCE: So how
do you get-- just,
do you get time
variations in those data,
or is it just a cross-section?
PROFESSOR: It's both a
cross-section and panel.
You use both aspects.
The best way to think about
having multiple intermediaries
is there's ex-ante
competition among them
to service households,
but there's
something committing
households once they sign up
to a long-term agreement.
So what's the initial state
for a household saying?
Well, for sure at least
the initial capital stock
when we visit them in
the baseline survey.
And then the second
argument depends
on the financial regime.
If it's like
borrowing and lending,
then it's their current assets
or their net indebtedness.
Or if it's one of
these contract regimes,
it's essentially some utility
constraint, some reservation
utility as if it had been
promised in the past.
And I'll say more about that.
That's the key to handling
the dynamic incentive problem.
Clearly, something like
unobserved utility is not seen,
so we're going to have
to parameterize it
with the mean and the variance
and estimate this unobserved
distribution of debt or
promises in the population.
Timing-- OK, so those
are initial states.
Then capital is
used in production
along with effort,
which may or may not
be observed depending
on the regime.
Output is realized.
There is this pre-existing
financial contract which
determines the debt, say,
that they can take on,
or savings for tomorrow, or
transfers as an insurance.
And finally, after
that financial stuff,
they eat some and
invest the rest.
So it's kind of like a
standard neoclassical setup.
Capital today, you
produce with labor,
then you can either
eat or invest.
The fancy stuff is happening
with the financial part, which
is the difference between
what you have available
and what you either
give up or get depending
on the financial contract.
Capital depreciates.
That's pretty standard.
And of course, then you
go to the next prime--
next period with all these
prime variables on them,
so the transition
from the state today
to the state tomorrow with a
financial contract in between.
OK.
In particular,
we're going to talk
about what goes on within
the period in terms
of the effort, which
is induced or assigned,
the output, which
happens through Mother
Nature, the decision
for capital tomorrow--
and I'll go more into this
promised utility for tomorrow.
This pi thing is
like the probability
of this whole quadruple.
And it looks daunting.
Now, from a statistical point
of view, it's like a histogram.
If you had a finite
number of values that q,
z, k prime and w
prime can take on,
then you just have a bunch of
points in dimensional space.
And then you can talk about
what mass, what height of a bar,
of a histogram bar that
those values take on.
So statistically, it's an easy
way to summarize the data.
From the point of view
of a financial contract,
there's a lot of degeneracy.
So it's not true, for
example, typically
that effort is random.
For a given set of parameter
values given incentives,
there's one effort
that's going to happen
and none of the other happen.
That's not
inconsistent with this.
It's just an extreme case
where almost everything is zero
except for one point of
effort, and that's one.
It's also true that there might
be a functional relationship
between consumption and output,
maybe a nice, smooth function.
Or if you want to
grid it up, you've
got a series of dots
that lie on a line.
So then we talk about the
probability of Q and C
as if know it was a shotgun.
But in practice, all the mass
is going to lie on that line.
So you're used to
thinking about,
let c be a function of q.
Let effort be assigned.
We'll take care of how much
capital is invested, et cetera.
OK.
It is true also that capital
might be indivisible.
We've talked about this.
You get project ideas.
You may or may
not want to do it.
The equipment is really
chunky, building that warehouse
for the chickens.
So that's actually
more realistic.
And then the probability
is kind of serious, which
is, what is the probability
you're going to do it,
or what fraction of the
population are going to do it?
When we talk about
fractions of the population,
you should be
reminded of Rogerson.
There it was you work
overtime or you work
or you don't work at
all, and the issue
was what fraction of
people are working.
So that was the first
experience in this class where
we had a probability number.
And when we have
non-convexities,
this is the generalization of
it to [INAUDIBLE] probabilities
on--
potentially on more
than one thing.
And there's a reason, and I'll
show you when we write it down.
It turns everything into a
linear programming problem.
I'm going to talk about
particular utility
functions, particular
production functions.
But really, we don't
need to assume--
that's both the strength
and limitation of this.
I'm not going to show you a
lot of closed-form analytic
solutions.
But on the other hand, we can
solve anything numerically.
And Cynthia, again,
just to alert you,
was backing out
from Euler equations
with first-order conditions,
which Lagrange multipliers are
binding and why and so on.
So it's not like you can't--
you can, in principle,
do both, actually.
You don't necessarily have to--
OK.
So let's just think
about a standard problem
without the lotteries.
This is the autarky problem.
Household enterprise
has a realized output q,
depreciated capital
from last period.
Actually, it's to qi
it's already realized.
In autarky, there's nothing
left other than deciding on what
to eat and what to invest.
So this is the capital
stock for tomorrow.
Oh, sorry.
And then there's this effort z.
z is entering in this utility.
It's also entering in
this production function.
You want expected utility?
Fine.
Just sum up over all
possible outputs,
taking into account
Mother Nature's way
of determining stochastically
what those outputs are.
And whatever you decide
to take over to tomorrow
enters in the value
function tomorrow.
OK?
So we're looking for this
infinite horizon solution.
We're looking for a
value function that's
like a fixed point that
solves the functional
equation like this.
Now, again, when qi
is realized, you still
have to decide on investment.
That's why i is on
both k prime and q.
But z is determined
before output is realized.
So that's just one number.
You with me?
OK.
It looks-- this is an
equivalent problem.
And this looks familiar,
except the i's are missing.
So it's output plus depreciated
capital less investment
for tomorrow, deciding
on [INAUDIBLE],,
but now we've taken this
deterministic-looking problem
and just replaced it with
this probability object.
But it allows all
these special cases.
Anything that can
solve this solves
this subject to grids,
subject to approximating
with a finite number
of outputs, et cetera.
All right.
Now, it looks here as
if the choice object
is this probability number
including the probability
of output, but how can that be?
Because Mother
Nature plays a role.
So we kind of have to constrain
these histograms to respect
the relationship between kz
and q, and namely, this object.
We don't want to
lose this object.
Well, it's a fancy way of
saying the probability of event
A conditioned on event b
times the probability event b
is the same thing as a
joint event a, comma, b.
So this was the probability
of q bar and z bar
because I summed
over everything else.
This is a probability
of c bar given z bar,
and then this is, summing
over everything else,
the probability of z bar.
So it's a cute trick.
So we're not going to
cheat on Mother Nature.
We're constrained to
follow Mother Nature.
Another thing to-- say
what's the dimensionality?
Well, the state variable
is k, so the question is,
how many little k's are there?
If we grid up k in the
small, medium, and large,
there's three of
them, for example.
It could be 10.
That's our choice in
terms of the grid.
But whatever it is, we've got to
solve this functional equation
v and find the fixed
point by iterating.
OK?
And the larger is the
dimension of this,
the harder it is to do that.
Jan.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
formulations [INAUDIBLE]??
In the second case,
as in the agents
can do some randomization
[INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I should have--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] is
the first case [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
If we don't get the grid
right-- for example,
if we have a continuum of
values of z, and so on,
then we have to make sure
that the solution here
is on a grid point down here.
Or to put it the
other way around,
if the grid is serious
then the household
may want to optimize in terms
of choosing a probability.
And in that case, this is
not just going to replicate.
This allows more.
So if it wants to, we
can find a solution,
but it may choose to
find something else.
There are grid lotteries,
but it's too easy
to detect them in the output.
You've got medium
effort and high effort,
and then the thing is putting
probability on both of those.
They're like adjacent points.
So it's clear
where the program's
trying to get something in
the middle that's just not
available.
And if the grid is serious,
then, as in Rogerson,
that's fine.
If we think the grid
ought to be not there,
and it's just meant to
be an approximation,
then you probably want to
slice and dice it a bit more
and search more intensively
between those adjacent points.
AUDIENCE: For the
second problem,
is it possible that the solution
[INAUDIBLE] random contract?
PROFESSOR: It is possible, yes.
AUDIENCE: But in reality,
why the agent can randomly
choose a [INAUDIBLE]
So [INAUDIBLE]
the first formulation,
a agent can not
choose a random contract.
And in the second
one, you can choose.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
I agree with your point.
You think it's
infeasible to randomize?
AUDIENCE: So I think
if your assumption
is that the [INAUDIBLE]
agent can do randomization,
then I agree that these
[INAUDIBLE] formulations
are equivalent.
But if you don't assume that--
PROFESSOR: I am assuming they
can do the randomization.
And again, as in
Rogerson, it's a way
to smooth out the
non-convexities.
That's the main--
you know, we've
turned non-convex problems
into a linear program.
Oh, why is it a linear
programming problem?
Well, these pis are
the choice variables.
It's tempting to say, oh, no,
it's supposed to be k and z.
No, no, no.
It's the probability of
[? qt ?] So this is just
a number, this utility, if you
were to do a certain quadruple.
And this is the probability
of that quadruple.
So these are the fundamental
policy variables.
And what is the
dimensionality of them?
Number q cross number
z cross number k prime.
So this can get pretty
big pretty fast.
And how many
constraints there are?
Well, in this case, just the
one, although probabilities do
have to add up.
But essentially, one constraint.
Well, not quite.
It's for every q bar and z bar.
So actually, there's number
q cross number z constraints
here.
I'm not going to belabor this.
But when you go through
the other regimes,
you're going to keep an eye
on how many constraints there
are and so on.
And eventually,
we'll get to regimes
that are actually nice and
challenging to compute.
Here's the--
AUDIENCE: I still don't
understand exactly what you
mean when you say that the
pis are the choice variables
and the q and the k's and
the z's are just numbers.
I mean, they still
ought to be consistent.
So when you choose a
pi, then you're doing--
PROFESSOR: Suppose you had
a continuous consumption
schedule, so c is
a function of q.
And then the paradigm
is either you work hard
or you work very little,
so there's just two.
So if you choose
not to work hard,
that's going to be
reflected in output.
But you're still facing
that consumption schedule.
Or you could work hard
or potentially randomize
across working hard or not.
So the randomization
could be in the effort.
AUDIENCE: So the
pis are functions?
I'm choosing a function.
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: I'm
choosing a function.
PROFESSOR: Actually,
here, it's so general
that you don't
see any functions.
You're just choosing mass
points over a finite number
of q's, z's, and k primes
without constraints.
AUDIENCE: I am, quote
unquote, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it more like
choosing a distribution,
though, instead of saying--
PROFESSOR: If
these were-- yeah--
if these were a
continuum, then this
would be like a density, a
multi-dimensional density.
But I don't know how
to compute those.
AUDIENCE: It's not-- so
correct me if I'm wrong,
but it's not that I can
put anything next to it.
I have to plug in
to the u next to it
the corresponding
stuff in there.
But then I just compute every
single thing inside there
and choose the best one
after I compute everything.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So we specify the grids.
So we know the set of
feasible choices for all
the quadruples qzk prime.
For any particular one, we
know what this real number is.
You use Matlab code to
generate these weights.
In this case, it's a weight on
it on the objective function,
or you use codes to
generate this guy,
and then there's weights
on the constraint set.
So
AUDIENCE: So now
I understand that.
But then, in some sense,
I don't understand
what the difference
from the first case is--
like, for on the first problem.
That the probability
of q given k
and z could, in
principle, be non-linear.
And so we're just--
PROFESSOR: It's the extra
gain from randomization.
I mean, suppose--
take the point of view
that there are a
continuum of-- well,
so far we don't have
the social planner.
I mean, this is just an
individual optimization.
But I will try to
answer your question.
When we have a village-wide
resource constraint,
we've got to decide how
many resources to use up
in investment and how much to
leave over for consumption.
And it may be that you
don't want everyone
doing a large, chunky project.
You want to just take
some people to do it
and some people not.
And then you know whatever
is produced as output,
use that some of that
for consumption and some
to save for tomorrow.
So from a social
perspective, you rarely
want everyone doing
the same thing.
You want to choose the
fractions or people doing
one thing or the other.
Does that help?
All right.
So this is with
borrowing and lending,
so it's essentially
almost the same,
except you can add to
your current resources
by borrowing, except
you've got to pay back
your loan from yesterday.
So now you've got two ways
to intertemporally reallocate
consumption, one through
the capital stock,
the equipment, and the other
through financial borrowing
and lending.
And it's already
written in lotteries.
By the way, it enhances
the state vector
from the capital stock to
the current debt as well.
Now we can knock
off savings only.
That's where a basically,
if B means borrowing,
then basically, it
can't be positive
if you're not going to allow it.
Or you could allow
some small amount
and have a positive
but low amount
that you could borrow as b max.
So we can do savings
only, et cetera.
If you don't want to limit
borrowing at all, that's fine.
Then you just let it
take on any value subject
to [? grade ?] issues.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: When you do this
kind of stuff in Matlab,
to do these different scenarios,
is that just [INAUDIBLE]
one line of code?
PROFESSOR: Which?
AUDIENCE: Like, to
have [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, actually, you can almost
generate it from the grid,
because you might have a
large set of possible values
for borrowing.
That would be the
unrestricted problem.
If you want savings
only, then you just
cut off all the positive
borrowings or anything
in between.
So this one you can handle
in terms of generating
the underlying grid.
Now we get to these
mechanism design models
including full information.
Now we're going to have to
go back to the households
as a group dealing with
this financial intermediary.
The main thing is this--
let's look at the household
because we were looking
at households a minute ago.
Now it's as if they surrendered
all their output to the bank--
bear with me-- but
they get some of it
back in terms of transfers.
Actually, a more
natural way to write it
would have been give them
q and let them pay back
loans, state-contingent loans.
It's equivalent.
The transfer can be
positive or negative.
And it's kind of the
basis of consumption,
but it's adjusted, as
usual, by investment.
So then the contract has to
solve for these transfers,
and the transfers
are a function of q.
Now, as I said, the
way this is written,
the q ends up with
the bank, but the bank
is paying the transfer.
So this is basically a surplus
generated from households.
What fraction of households
have output q greater than tau,
so the bank is getting
money from them?
Well, that's this pi.
That's the fraction.
Well, you know, it's
infinite horizon.
So this is the surplus
generated today--
or if negative, the loss--
summed up over all
surpluses and losses
depending on who's
at what states
and what the contract assigns.
And then you have
tomorrow's profits.
This is a small, open economy.
There's an interest
r, 1 plus a little r.
So this is just the
present value of tomorrow.
So this is surplus
today plus profits today
plus profits tomorrow.
So it's as if the bank is trying
to maximize overall profits.
Now, what's the constraint?
Why not just screw
the households?
Well, the answer is--
it's not quite
right, but you can
think about this as a
reservation utility.
So you can't take too much away.
Otherwise, the households
will cry foul and walk away.
OK?
Actually, technically,
this promise
was predetermined from
the previous period.
Or equivalently, part
of the control variable
is the promise from
tomorrow on, w prime.
It's easy and yet
amazingly powerful.
So just think about incentives.
You have long-term contracts.
Should I work today?
I can get rewarded or
penalized depending
on what my output is today.
But it's not just
a static contract.
There's tomorrow too.
So maybe my history
of observed outputs
will be used tomorrow in terms
of the insurance and credit
contract I'm going to
get, which in turn could
be used in the third period.
And we're like, oh, my god.
That's a really big object.
But no.
What do the
households care about?
They only care about
their expected utility.
If I'm looking
forward to tomorrow,
I don't have to solve
tomorrow's problem
as long as I know what the
utility consequences will be.
So this is kind
of a reduced form
way of handling the
multi-period incentive problem.
What I'm saying is the
household's expected utility
is the utility outcome from
today plus the expected utility
tomorrow.
It's not only--
it's the probability
of being assigned w prime
tomorrow jointly with output
today.
So now, not only is
consumption moving up and down
with output today--
and it will move when
there's limited insurance--
but also, tomorrow's utility
will vary up and down.
And because you have concave
utility and this force
for inter-temporal smoothing,
you won't just do one,
and you won't just do the other.
Actually, you'll load as much
into the future as possible.
Front loading is a bad thing.
The longer the horizon,
the more powerful
the incentives, because
you've got the whole future.
So there's a lot of
economics behind this sort
of innocuous-looking
two-period problem
where w prime captures tomorrow.
All right.
That's actually the
full insurance problem,
and then we can
add moral hazard.
So basically, what this says
is if z bar is assigned today
in the contract and the
guy actually does it,
he has to be wanting
to do it relative to--
and the bank wouldn't
know even though z
bar is being recommended, the
guy is doing z hat, shirking.
So this is a standard
moral hazard constraint.
Of course, the
inequality makes them
want to do the recommendation.
But the program has to
evaluate any possible deviation
a shirking agent
might do and make
sure the utility
consequences for the agent
are worse than following
the recommended plan.
Now, again, because
we've embedded
Mother Nature in
this pi thing, we
have to re-normalize
the probability.
I actually showed you this once.
But I'm sure with discounting,
you can't remember backwards.
More on that next Tuesday.
But we just adjust
the likelihood
to reflect the fact that now z
hat is taken rather than z bar.
And it's not maybe obvious
where this is coming from.
It is nevertheless true.
You just have to write out all
the conditional probabilities
and start summing up.
I can give you a
reference if you want
to see where it's written out.
Questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I just
want to make sure
that I understand
this formulation.
So I think the [? language ?]
of this formulation
is that if you don't have this
formulation, first of all,
you need to solve the
incentive-compatible contracts
one by one.
And in this case, the
randomizing contract
is like randomize your wealth.
So you may need to
solve one problem.
So I [INAUDIBLE] you randomize--
PROFESSOR: Well,
actually, you're
suggesting a simplification
that we're not
using, which is any random--
oh, you mean the w, the promise?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think the advantage of
the second formulation
compared to the first line--
in the first line, you
need to solve first
all the incentive-compatible
contracts,
and then you'll do an
optimal randomization
among these contracts.
Right?
Here you can just--
x and t, you can randomize
over this z and the k,
and that will give
you a similar result.
So essentially, you only need
to solve one linear programming
problems instead of a lot.
Is that--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Well, I guess.
We're searching jointly
over all the possibilities.
Now, it's true on the one hand,
it's just a linear programming
problem.
So we can just get the best
code available and use it.
On the other hand, there's lots
of variables, lots of states,
lots of constraints.
So it's not like
it comes for free.
If I knew something analytically
about the underlying contract,
it would be good to use it.
But if I don't know,
then I could just
guess wrong and put
some functional form
which is incorrect.
And that's why-- that's
what's good about this.
I don't-- now, what was
Victor talking about?
Victor was talking about going
back to deterministic contracts
and then solving them with a
nonlinear optimization problem
and then comparing that
solution to these linear codes.
And I'm not sure if he
showed you at the end,
but when the grids
are really coarse,
the linear program
seems to work,
but it can be a really
bad approximation.
So there's still trade-offs.
It's not a miracle.
Other questions?
All right.
So now we can do
limited commitment.
So this is what I mentioned.
You can go into autarky.
You can decide to do that
after your output is realized.
It's like, I'm not paying
into the risk-sharing group.
Great.
You financed my project.
I'm the big boss now, and I'd
just as soon be on my own.
So what we say is--
first of all, we compute the
value function for autarky.
Well, that's cool.
We already did that.
That was the first
financial regime.
So we already know this guy.
And then the
contemporary situation
is you've got output
plus depreciated capital,
and then you could walk away.
No transfers.
They're gone.
You just keep it
all and decide maybe
what you want to
carry into tomorrow.
So we can call the solution
to this thing omega.
By the way, the z
is already foregone.
You've already
made that decision.
It was in disutility part.
You've already got capital.
You already got funding.
Now you have output.
Can't go backwards,
but you can walk away.
So this is basically
the maximizing utility.
And we make sure that
if you follow the plan,
you're not going to
be tempted to do that.
So compute v, then compute this.
Then we have this, and then you
impose this as a constraint.
So this is a limited
commitment constraint.
We've talked about
collateral constraints.
It's very related to that.
You can walk away,
but you might--
with collateral, you have
to sacrifice something.
Not here.
They actually keep
all of their capital.
If we had financial savings,
then they would lose that.
They would lose the stuff
they had in the bank.
AUDIENCE: So what
keeps me from doing
that is that the
continued valuation is
going to be on that side?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is playing ball, and this
is being tempted to pull out.
It doesn't mean that it isn't
binding on the solution.
This can do damage.
It could be a binding constraint
and have a big Lagrange
multiplier.
So the solution
will look different.
But you never see the
out-of-equilibrium event
that they walk away.
But the damage can be done.
Not getting a whole
lot of capital,
not having a whole
lot of insurance--
those things happen.
I mean, again, it's rich
guys who would prefer, say,
not to pay into the system.
They're going to be tempted.
So you start eliminating
the people that pay in,
and that starts limiting
the insurance, et cetera,
et cetera.
And then finally, we
have this hidden output.
So here, the idea is income
is produced, all right,
but the outsiders
don't see what it is.
OK.
But then you say,
well, tell me anyway.
Send me a message.
So the idea here
is q is actually--
q bar is actually realized,
and the business says so.
Believe me.
My profits are low.
Or-- and they are low.
Or q bar is realized, but we
have this counterfactual where
he says something else about q.
Maybe in that
particular period, it
was advantageous to say profits
are really, really high,
or it could be vice versa.
When they're high, you say high.
When they're low,
you're tempted--
sorry.
When they're low, you say low.
And when they're high,
you're tempted to say low.
All right?
This allows for any q that they
will, quote, tell the truth.
Well, great.
It's just another inequality.
No problemo.
We know how to
generate constraints.
But again, it will
do different damage.
There's going to be consequences
for the underlying contract.
And remember, the goal
here is to get to the data.
You can assume these
parametric utility functions--
constant relative risk aversion,
power sigma, disutility
of effort, a power
of Frisch elasticity.
OK?
So 3-- we're going to
be limited, actually.
We're going to estimate
sigma and theta, xe equal 1.
Here's a production function.
We actually load in
an observed histogram.
But you can do constant
elasticity of substitution
if you want.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: So you [? test ?] one
where you can verify a state?
Because now the output
is hidden, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I didn't do it.
AUDIENCE: Why not?
PROFESSOR: I forgot about
costly state application.
But anyway, it's doable.
Hong's working on it.
And these other things,
like the discount rate,
the depreciation rate,
the outside interest rate,
and so on.
So this is very much in
the spirit of calibration.
These numbers are
similar to numbers
you've seen in various
papers in the classes trying
to be somewhat realistic.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: When we're [INAUDIBLE]
looking at the matrix p of q
given c an dk.
Is that just for setting up
the moral hazard constraint?
PROFESSOR: No.
We need that in general.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So we're going to say
that we see effort even though,
in the models, sometimes
it's unobserved.
I mean, the question is what
an outside lender would see,
not what the households tell
us when we interview them.
So anyway, we take
the stand that we
see a good version of
it, and capital as well,
and we see output.
And I think that--
let's see where that is.
Oh, my god.
It's way-- there it was.
So there is an
empirical histogram
of capital, labor, and output.
I don't know if you really
get a three-dimensional view
of that thing.
I can kind of see it's bending
over here, and then [INAUDIBLE]
flip on me.
But-- so we can load that
in, or we can actually say,
no, no, no, it's CES, some
elasticity of substitution,
and estimate whether it's
[INAUDIBLE] for linear
or stuck in between.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] question.
On graphic views, is there a
way to understand [INAUDIBLE]
whether those--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but
it's kind of hard
because I don't know
what this thing is doing.
It doesn't look visually
like it kept going down.
It may actually come back.
By the way, it makes my point.
We don't have to assume
any kind of concavity
in the underlying primitives.
If it has this sort of
scallop shape, wonderful.
Bring on the lotteries.
Then it will span the arc line.
We can even allow
risk-loving households here.
I mean, there's
really no restriction
in the underlying perimeters.
We have parameterized utilities
to make people risk-averse,
but in principle, we don't
have to put restrictions
on what we load in.
OK.
So preferences, technology--
I'll just say a few words
about dimensionality.
As we go through autarky
savings, full information,
moral hazard, et
cetera, you can start
counting the number of
linear programs that
need to be solved, the number
of variables in each program,
the numbers of constraints.
I didn't even dare show you
this unobserved investment one,
but the hidden output
is getting up there too.
We actually have a technology
to compute these things
with hundreds of
thousands of constraints.
I mean, the commercial
code is CPLEX,
and there's open freeware
that's comparable to it.
It's the latest
Princeton interior point.
It's not just a
simplex algorithm.
You can use it as a
student, actually.
It cost me a couple
thousand dollars.
But anyway, so we can
handle fairly large numbers.
Now, that said, what's
the tension here?
Well, you're going
to see not only
do you have to iterate
off the value functions
and solve the linear program
at each iteration and solve--
this is just one step.
But then we don't even know
what the parameters are.
So then we got to do it for all
the set of possible parameters
and generate a likelihood.
So these guys start to get
demanding not because you can't
solve it once in
20 or 30 seconds,
but because you've got to do it
hundreds and hundreds of times.
So you can understand
why there's
a big interest in having
relatively efficient code.
It starts to constrain you in
terms of the kinds of problems
you really want to consider.
All right.
So how does it work
computationally?
Well, once you solve for the
optimizing policy pi star,
you have a transition
function, basically.
You start with promised
utility and capital
today, integrate
out over everything
else other than capital
and utility tomorrow,
and you get the
probability of that.
So you get this
Markov object, right?
It's simple enough
conceptually--
the probability of states
tomorrow given states today.
So that's kind of the
underlying dynamic engine
that's chugging along for each
one of these financial regimes.
And then any time you
pick up certain w and k
in the solution, you can
generate the contract,
because that's the stuff
that we just integrated out.
But it's still there.
You can still use it.
So we can generate
histograms, CQ configurations.
We can have two cross-sections.
We can have panel.
There are some limits in terms
of the length of the panel
that we can actually use.
You still with me?
We've got to estimate
some parameters,
so we're going to have
these underlying structural
parameters.
We don't see, say, the
distribution of promised
utility, so we're going to
imagine that's generated maybe
like a normal distribution
with a certain mean
and a certain variance, and
we have to estimate those.
Better yet would be
a mixture of normals
which can approximate
any old thing you want,
but that raises the dimensions.
And we're trying to be lean in
terms of numbers of parameters.
So what do I mean by likelihood?
The probability of
getting observables y,
which could be in a
static cross-section,
values of consumption, output,
investment, and capital.
What's the probability of seeing
a particular configuration
like that given the
observed capital today
as a function of these
underlying parameter values?
So because the model is
already using lotteries,
you already get the
probability of these objects.
It just sort of comes
for free as part
of the optimizing solution.
Now, the next thing is, do
we see things perfectly?
No, not necessarily.
We can put in--
let me jump a second.
We can put in measurement
error and say if c star at j
were the true value,
we don't see it.
We see some measured
version with error.
So this is classic
econometric contamination,
classical measurement error.
We can put that on
everything that you like.
And then the program
would say, what
is the probability
the underlying output
and consumption would
be c star and q star?
That we generate from the code.
And then we can say, well,
what we see is c having q hat,
so that could come from
any c star and q star.
So you get a new sort of
distribution of observables.
Well, that's what I
just said in words.
Well, what's the point
of the likelihood?
We actually have the
data, and we see people
with a certain capital stock
getting a certain output
and having a
certain consumption,
investing a certain amount.
These are our observables.
And so we see the
histogram in the data,
and now we have a
histogram in the model.
So we can say, does it--
what parameters would
best rationalize the data
if the data came from
that financial regime,
a particular one?
So let me-- so I said
we have these data.
This is Kansas and the Rocky
Mountains for Thailand.
A mixed metaphor, but
it's also the investment.
Consumption is,
again, pretty flat,
so it's going to
suggest a regime where
there's a lot of
consumption smoothing
against income fluctuations.
On the other hand,
investment isn't flat.
And I haven't even shown you
the transitions in the capital
stock.
So when you-- you pick the
rural data, and you use, say--
say choose consumption
and output only.
There's a tie.
If you believed it was moral
hazard regime-- for example,
it's estimating the
degree of risk aversion
at 1.02, the Frisch
elasticity at 1.6.
It's got a certain mean and
variance of this underlying
unseen distribution of promised
utilities and an estimate
of the measurement error.
And it does this for
each financial regime
against the same data.
And then we use this sort
of information criterion,
which Vong created,
which allows testing
across non-nested regimes.
In this case, it's a tie.
But if you went to the
investment data alone,
it would be savings,
savings only.
So in the rural data,
we get a limited regime.
I probably won't have time
to show you the Monte Carlos.
The Monte Carlos are like this.
You pick a set of parameter
values, maybe the ones
we estimate in the
data, for example,
and then generate the
data from the model,
and then go through all of this.
And depending on the degree
of measurement area--
error that you use to
contaminate the data, you can--
especially when you use joint
consumption and investment
data, you pretty much
get back what you put in,
which is reassuring.
But it's a bit black boxy.
We don't have an analytic proof.
So if you use consumption data
alone, two cross-sections,
you can use two-year panels.
Then there's-- in
the rural data,
it's kind of hard to
pin down too much.
In terms of the regime,
moral hazard is in there.
Sometimes full
information is in there.
Limited commitment is in there.
But again, when you use
the investment data alone
or use the joint data,
it's pretty clear
that savings only, no
borrowing, buffer stock model
is the one that the
data like the best.
But when we-- if we
use the network alone--
you're saying, well,
you've contradicted-- no.
Like, what Cynthia
and I do, and so on,
we can actually get the
full information regime out
of the consumption data.
So that's very reassuring
because in those other papers,
we didn't use this method.
There's a lot of consumption
smoothing among the networks.
And if we go to
the urban data, we
get this result that even when
we use the investment data,
it's the moral hazard regime,
not the limited savings
only regime.
So they're different across
the two specifications,
although it is true that if you
used the investment data alone,
it would still like savings.
So there's still this--
and we've talked about this--
money doesn't flow from
unproductive to productive
people the way these relatively
unconstrained regimes would
imply.
However, if you looked at
the consumption data jointly,
then it's one likelihood.
And it decides in the urban area
that, oh, well, moral hazard
actually fits better
than savings only,
but the reverse is
true in the rural data.
So although the investment
data doesn't fit perfectly well
in the urban data,
the verdict is
we do a ton of
robustness checks.
And I'll skip it.
So let me just--
I really want to say
something about heterogeneity,
but I'd rather show you three
slides before I quit-- namely,
in the actual rural data,
this sort of diagonal
here represents the persistence
of the capital stock.
So it doesn't move much.
It moves very slowly.
You can hardly see
mass off the diagonal.
In the urban data,
it's still sluggish,
but at least you
can move away more.
If you have this wonderful
financial regime,
you're going to adjust almost
instantaneously to the observed
productivity.
So this speed of adjustment
of the capital stock
is really the thing
that's kind of pushing
the likelihood toward
limited financial regimes.
By the way, these are
the best-fitting regimes
through the lens
of the model, which
still have an excessive
amount of smoothing.
These are the time series--
levels of consumption over time,
levels of the capital stock,
levels of income.
We did not use all of this data.
This is like setting aside
certain things in the data
and then looking after the
fact as a new criterion.
And we're doing pretty well.
The standard deviations,
we do less well,
but for obvious reasons that
there are stuff in the tails
that the model doesn't like.
But if we smooth
off 1% of the tails
and kind of get rid
of it, we actually
bring the standard deviations
generated by the model much,
much closer to the data.
And we can actually use
the level on borrowing,
which we didn't use [? an ?]
[? estimate, ?] and got really,
really close to that.
And finally, here is
this data on the return
on assets with these low-wealth
households having high returns.
And the savings only
regime which fits best
is trying to do that.
And this is the urban
data, which is already
a little more
dispersed, but it still
has this low-wealth,
high-return guise.
And it can generate
that somewhat
with this moral hazard.
So these are the
familiar objects
that we've been looking at.
And finally, let me
just end with this.
Sorry.
I guess that discussion
at the beginning of class
took a chunk of time.
So if you believe
the structural model,
you can do policy evaluation.
And here we're doing
something simple
like just changing
the interest rate.
Now, the point is some people
win, and some people lose.
And also, who are the
winners and the losers
depends on the financial regime.
So this is the consumption
equivalent welfare gain
of lowering the interest rate.
Negative and positive--
this is as we
vary the level of
current savings
and the level of assets.
But this is what it would look
like if it were not the savings
regime, but the borrowing regime
at the estimated parameters
we get.
And then this is the
difference of those two.
So it's another
difference and difference,
but it's a difference
in the welfare criteria
across two financial regimes.
And the point is it
matters quite a lot,
if you did this interest
rate subsidy, what
the financial regime is in
terms of who wins and who loses.
These are non-trivial
gains, and so on.
All right.
I'll quit there.